hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in metaphysics book one in addition to
outlining his teacher Plato's
metaphysical views in terms of form and
material objects Aristotle will also go
on to spend even more space criticizing
that very account primarily the notion
of the forms as contributing to wisdom
and knowledge that is he's not only
attacking some of the internal coherence
of the account he's even saying that
this doesn't help us understand reality
any better and he sets out a number of
different points which I've summarized
here brought under different headings
and some of them are spread out in
different portions of the text but all
of them are relatively distinct from
each other and you can see that there
are a number of different ways in which
he has problems and raises issues with
this metaphysical account so what is
Plato's metaphysical account we should
start by sort of just remembering that
the idea is that there are forms or I
Jia's and these are as aristotle is
gonna say one over many and this is a
formula that was probably in use at the
time quite commonly to explain how the
forms were were supposed to be
conceptualized you have many different
instances of things for example human
being and then there'll be one form that
unites and somehow you know gives the
what it is for that thing to be to all
of the individual instances and that one
form is most real and I as human being
or you as human being are less real
we're at best copies imitations we
participate in some way in the ideal
form and Plato uses the term idea he
uses the term [ __ ] he uses the term part
of DAG ma which means something like
pattern uses a number of different ways
to try to get this across sometimes he
has Socrates talked about the thing out
toasts or out own or Altay which means
itself you know courage itself or the
bed itself any of those sorts of things
the forms are in material and
intelligible and all the things that
they are the form of are usually
material right material plural visible
sensible things changeable things the
forms are also immutable and eternal and
all the changeable things are
destructible they come into being they
are in a state of perpetual flux and in
a certain respect they're not really
what they purport themselves as being so
the the physical bed is not really as
much bed as is the form of the bed and
you already see a kind of weird sense in
which we're talking about this you what
do you mean the physical bed is not the
real bed all right there's a there's a
shift that has to take place according
to Plato which he calls contemplation
and dialectic these are the ways to get
to this
things in that light now Aristotle
studied with Plato and presumably had
the opportunity to bring up these
objections and to get answers at many
points so we should we should take his
objections quite seriously
one of the first objections that he
makes and he does this at multiple
points in the text is that there are
going to be a lot of forms now that by
itself wouldn't necessarily be a damning
criticism Aristotle's not saying we want
it to be simple you know I'm kind of
lazy I don't want to have to think about
more than five four versus something it
like that he's fine are there being a
lot of forms but the problem is it seems
like we might not be able to put a limit
on the number of forms and if the goal
is to have some sort of account that
provides intelligibility it provides the
basis for knowledge of wisdom that's
gonna be a problem so he actually says
here we go in the first place this is
about those who posit the forms as
causes in their attempt to find the
causes of things in our sensible world
they introduced an equal number of other
entities as though a man who wishes to
count things should suppose that it
would be impossible when they're few and
should attempt to count them when he's
added to them for the forms are as many
as or not fewer than the things in
search of whose causes these thinkers
were led to the forums why because
corresponding to each thing there is a
synonymous that's called by the same
name entity apart from the substances
and in the case of non substantial
things there is a one over the many both
in our everyday world and in the realm
of eternal entities so we're making the
account actually more complicated by
introducing form so that that may not be
that big of a problem of course if they
do contribute a kind of intelligibility
to things but the problem is that
there's going to be
not only forms of the things that we
want to identify is it think you know
what Plato focuses on the virtues what's
the form of justice what's the form of
courage what's the form of piety is
there a form of justice per se that
unites all of these forms that that's a
you know valuable question we probably
do want to be able to bring under one
heading all the material instances other
things that we call courage that so we
can understand what they would be and we
could try to guide other people towards
courageous activities or courageous
dispositions but what about other things
Aristotle says you're going to have a
lot of problems here he says that there
will be forms of all things of which
there are Sciences or disciplinary types
of knowledge and according to the one
over many argument of negations - so you
will not just have forms of things that
are but also of things that are not and
you're going to have some conception of
perishable things so you're gonna have
to have forms of those things and he
says of Plato's more exact arguments
some established ideas of relations
relations are where you have two things
two substances and they're connected
with each other in a certain way like
father and son right or greater and
lesser I suppose you know it's debatable
about exactly what kind of relation that
that is but these will become forms so
fatherhood presumably would be a form
but that's gonna raise all sorts of
problems now it seems like we have not
only do we have a whole bevy of forms
out there but not all the forms are of
substances and so they're not leading us
to what actually is substance we'll come
back to that slightly and some of these
other arguments the next thing that that
he brings up is a very famous argument
called the third
and this is one that that Plato actually
brings up against his own work in
another dialogue right and so how does
this go it says well you've got the
you've got the thing the material thing
in this case we'll use man and then
you've got the form of the thing how are
these they actually connected why is the
form of the thing the form of this thing
and all of the things like it you could
have a whole bunch of men and or human
being and then you've got the form which
is not with them it's something separate
from them exist an intelligible world of
man how do you know that these actually
correlate to each other well there has
to be a third man that they both refer
to in some way so in what you're saying
is there actually has to be like another
form because it couldn't be something
material or it has to be something other
than forms and then once you've got that
one and you say well that's that's how
this you know connection occurs or is
identified between the individual
material sensible man and the form the
idea of man this third man is the thing
that mediates between the two well how
do you know that that one actually is
the mediator and that's some other thing
oh well we need a fourth one and you see
where this can go on to infinity there
are some internal problems with this
argument and there's there's some
problematic assumptions being made as
well but it's it's an interesting
argument to make against Plato and as I
pointed out one that Plato himself knew
of as well another problem is that
things seemingly according to Plato's
account could participate in multiple
forms at the same time so I could for
example we won't use the one that he
actually uses first if I am courageous
but I'm also man it seems like I'm
participating in two different forms at
the same
but one of them is really as we could
say accidental to me and the other one
is not now Aristotle brings up something
that doesn't have to do with a human
being but rather with two things a
duality or a pair of things and the do
add the the primal - you could say that
is eternal but any two objects that we
put together they're not eternal so that
seems to raise a bit of a problem or at
least generate some sort of confusions
and Aristotle here is saying that there
are some some serious issues with the
possibility of participating in or
whatever participation means imitating
following the pattern of being named
after some of these these different
forms at the same time another probably
more damning argument has to do with how
it is that forms are supposed to be
clauses in the first place and Aristotle
you see them a little bit later say
wisdom is supposed to be concerned with
this material world and why things
change and why things are the way they
are and the forms don't actually seem to
contribute to that because how does
something that is eternal and unchanging
how does that bring about change how
does it produce things how does it bring
about motion even how does it bring
things in to exist and how does it cause
generation Plato is saying that somehow
it does this but Aristotle saying well
there's no good account of that and it's
rather counterintuitive that something
that is eternal would at this point in
time suddenly bring about these these
things it can't even account for the
existence
or the the being of those things this is
a pretty damning argument I think that
he's making here another big issue is
that if forms are supposed to be
patterns powdered egg Matta in the Greek
well who actually uses these forms to
bring about the material things that
they're supposed to be imitations or
participations or whatever it is that
they are in the forms and we might think
about Plato's example the the bed maker
the bed maker is he looking to the ideal
form he's if you were gonna go to a
carpenter and say hey where's the ideal
Horton you use
he'd say that in my toolbox let me see
if I can find what you're looking for
well it's you know the conception that
you have a bit oh you mean like the idea
in my head no no it's not in your head
so much as out there in an intelligible
world and you look to it the ideal bed
or badness itself or you know the bad
capital B capital T and he said well you
know maybe some bed makers do that but I
I don't actually work that way and I
think if we go to a lot of people and
ask them about their their work that
they're doing we would not find them
using Plato's ideal forms and Plato's
you know answer to that as well that's
why they do such sloppy work that's
that's in politics for example you know
politicians don't actually look to the
form of the good or justice or courage
they they have these mistaken
conceptions of what these things
actually are if they actually if they
had it completely correct and they were
you know trained from birth the way the
guardians are supposed to be in in in
learning these sorts of things well
politics would be much better Aristotle
says while you're trying to have it both
ways Plato you're trying to say that
people actually do use these forms but
they do it in a kind of what unconscious
or inchoate way and at the same time
these forms are supposed to be
what it is that would provide a genuine
account so how does anybody actually do
any good work that that would be a sort
of natural conclusion to this this
argument that we can provide he's got
another discussion as well about how two
things can be like each other something
can be like something else without being
imitated or derived from that that thing
he says that a man may become just like
Socrates whether Socrates exists or not
and even if Socrates were eternal
clearly the case would be the same so
you know he says some things are not in
any accepted sense derived from these
forms you know what what does it
actually mean maybe we don't actually
have to have the forms there as an
account to explain resemblance or
similarity or identity and difference or
any of these other sorts of things that
we we consider to be important
another question that he brings up and
this really goes to the heart of
Aristotle's own metaphysical account is
how can the substance
lúcia in this case the which would be
the form and the thing of which it is
the substance the the material thing how
can they exist in isolation or
separation from each other
and Aristotle here says where here we go
says what do they actually contribute to
sensible things they don't have any they
don't give us any help towards an
knowledge of these these things because
they are not present in the things that
that partake of them if they were it
might seem that they are causes in the
sense in which the admixture of white
causes a thing to be white but in this
theory which was first stated by the an
exact refutable and started saying the
forms aren't in the thing
but then how are they actually connected
up together if the form is supposed to
be the substance that you SIA of the
thing how do you have a thing at all
right and here is where we have to you
know fundamentally different
metaphysical views Aristotle does think
that the essence is in some sense in the
thing it is part of the composite of
form and matter that make the individual
particular Plato doesn't think that an
Aristotle thinks that that's incoherent
Aristotle also provides a lot of
discussion about why forms can't really
be numbers this one's a little bit
unfair if Plato in fact does think that
numbers are something that our form mole
but distinct from forms the things that
Aristotle brings up are you know for
example forms cannot be competence but
numbers can be composites you know Stix
is a composite of one plus two plus
three or it could be understood as two
times three whatever whatever it is you
want to do forms can't work that way
and Aristotle actually has a very
interesting complaint a little bit later
on that I think is worth bringing up
says that philosophy has become
mathematics for the thinkers of today
told Newton right although they profess
that mathematics is only to be studied
as a means for some other and so he's
saying listen you can't really bring
forms and numbers together like that and
then to wrap this up one of the
complaints that we see Aristotle make at
numerous points not only in the
metaphysics but also in other works is
that this very term participation meth X
in and the verb that it's derived from
met met at Kane doesn't really name
anything that we can put our finger up
doesn't really make sense it sounds good
but it's just using metaphorical
language it doesn't precise what it is
that is going on between the four
armed this eternal thing which is
somehow the substance of all the
material things that it's like in some
way and yet unlike in many relevant ways
it doesn't really convey anything so
calling it participation is just to use
a contemporary term kind of hand waving
rather than providing a genuine account
and so these are not all of the
criticisms that Aristotle makes of Plato
but these are a lot of interesting
criticisms that he does levy in this
part of metaphysics book one you can see
that as Plato's arguably most brilliant
student he thought there were in fact a
number of objections and obstacles that
could be brought up to the doctrine of
the forms which is a central aspect of
platonic metaphysics
you